off the coast of plymouth they're
planting hope
inside these hessian bags are seeds of
seagrass
dropped to the bottom by volunteers from
the ocean conservation trust
they should grow into a lush underwater
meadow
more than eighteen thousand bags will
cover an area equivalent to twelve
football pitches
seagrass is a bit of a super plant it's
really important
um provides us many ecosystem services
so it traps carbon from the atmosphere
does this really efficiently
can be up to 35 times more efficient
than rainforest in
capturing carbon in its sediment it
provides some protection from our storms
and wave events so it provides coastal
protection it buffers
against the impact of the sea seagrass
also
shelters five times as many fish as bare
seabed
but 92 of the meadows that once
surrounded the coast have been lost
largely because of pollution if
britain's sea grass meadows were
restored to how they once were
they'd store up to eleven and a half
million tons of carbon that's roughly
three percent
of our annual emissions it doesn't get
us off doing the hard stuff reducing our
own
emissions but nato-based solutions can
help
the planet is heading towards one and a
half degrees of warming and the tipping
points that could lead to the melting of
vast
ice sheets and die back of the amazon
but new research shows as long as it's
quickly cooled
the worst effects of climate change
could be avoided
we still need to put our efforts into
reducing
carbon emissions and taking carbon out
of the atmosphere reduce warming
because the safest option is still to
not cross these tipping point thresholds
if we were to cross a tipping point
threshold then the message is
don't give up because all hope is not
lost yet
there might still be this opportunity
that we can get back
and avoid the catastrophic change
nature removes carbon from the
atmosphere far more cheaply and
efficiently than any existing technology